الارقام النهائيه
52% لاردوغان مقابل
47.86 لكل جدار اوغلو نتحدث اذا المشاهدين
عن فرق حوالي اربع نقاط مئويه بين الرئيس
المنتهيه ولايته الذي اصبح الان رئيسا
لولايه ثالثه من خمس سنوات الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان مع منافسه
الرئاسيه كل جدار اوغلو عن المعارضه عن
تحالف يضم سته احزاب معارضه تركيا ولكن
هذه هي المره الاولى التي يتم الذهاب فيها
الى جوله اعاده الى جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعدما لم تحسم اذا
الجوله الاولى بين المرشحين الرئاسيين اذن
اردوغان فاز بهذه الجوله فاز بولايه
رئاسيه الثالثه في اخر التصريحات كما ذكرت
اذا رئيس اللجنه العليا للانتخابات اعلن
فوز اردوغان اذا بعد اتمام فرز كل الاصوات
زعيمه الحزب الجيد او الحزب الصالح
اردوغان وهي من ضمن الاحزاب ضمن الطاوله
السداسيه والاحزاب المعارضه السته خلف
كمال من الاكشنر زعيمه الحزب الصالح اذا
هل ات رجب طيب اردوغان على فوزه بجوله
الاعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكنها
قالت انها ستواصل كذلك مسيرتها كمعارضه
اكشنر اضافت في تصريحات بان النتائج اظهرت
ان هناك درسا كبيرا يحتاج اردوغان الى
تعلمه مشيره الى انها تامل في ان يكون
اردوغان رئيسا لجميع الاتراك في طبعا في
خضم هذه الاحتفالات التي نتابعها معكم
مشاهدينا اذا
لانصار الرئيس التركي الفائز رجب طيب
اردوغان مباشره من انقره في هذه الصور
المباشره الان طبعا مع صدور هذه النتائج
رغم طبعا فوز اردوغان الليره التركيه
انخفضت الى 20.05
الدولار بعد اعلان فوز اردوغان
بالانتخابات اذا الليره تراجعت مقابل
الدولار مع اعلان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
فوزه في هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وطبعا
هذا في انتظار طبعا المزيد من
الانعكاسات لهذا الفوز وبالنظر الى ما
سيقوم به الرئيس التركي من القيام به من
اجراءات في هذه الولايه الرئاسيه الجديده
الثالثه من جانبها المرشح الرئيسي الخاسر
كمال كلجدار اوغلو قال انه سيواصل النضال
على عكس توقعات بانه
سيستقيل من حزبه المرشح الرئاسي التركي
كمجدار اوغلو قال انه سيواصل قياده النضال
وذلك بعد ان اظهرت النتائج انه خسر ما قال
انه اكثر انتخابات غير عادله منذ سنوات في
مواجهه الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان في
الجدار اوغلوب اضاف انه حصل على نحو 47.9%
من الاصوات في ج وله الاعاده قال في
تصريحات له من انقره ان النتائج اظهرت
رغبه الناس في تغيير الحكومه الاستبداديه
كما وصفها وقال انه حزين بسبب المشكلات
التي ستواجهها تركيا حسب تعبيره لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات